so tonight is the second 2020 Democratic
primary debate for the presidential
nomination in 2020 still so many
candidates that it's going to be divided
up into two nights tonight is night one
tomorrow night is night two I will be
streaming live commentary of both nights
on YouTube hopefully you never know with
these things how aggressive the network
broadcasting the debate will be about
copyright and it's possible that they
will shut down my stream after five
minutes I don't know but I hope you'll
join me in any case for as long as it
goes on at youtube.com slash the david
pakman show we will do pre debate
discussion with the audience I will do
live commentary on the debate not too
much just the right amount and then
maybe we will open the phone lines after
and hear from people this is going to be
quite frankly the last debate for a
number of the Democratic candidates
tonight's debate is on CNN 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Time just like tomorrow night's
debate the polling and the fundraising
requirements are going way up between
now between the second debate and the
third debate which is going to be in
September more on that in a second so
first of all let's go back to the first
debate who was helped or hurt by that
first debate let's look at polling the
day before debate one and today to see
how things have changed since then the
first debate was on June 26 and 27 so
we'll look at polling from June 25th and
then we will look at polling from today
and what you will notice is that Joe
Biden is basically unchanged to Bernie
Sanders is down a couple of points
Elizabeth Warren is up a couple of
points Kamala Harris is up four points
from before the first debate Pete Budaj
edged down about a point better or work
down about a point Cory Booker down a
bit Andrew yang up a point and then a
bunch of the zeros and ones they're all
kind of like within the margin of error
and none of them have really changed I'm
not even including all of the zeros and
ones just for space purposes but the
headlines are that between the first
debate and the second the only
substantive changes are Kamala Harris is
up for remaining the big winner from the
debate although her polling numbers have
come down from where they peaked after
that
first debate Elizabeth Warren up a
couple of points
Biden basically even in the end he
declined after the first debate but now
has come back up and Bernie Sanders down
a couple of points now we can argue
about which polls are included I'm using
the Real Clear Politics averages on the
dates before each of these debates this
is more or less the picture no major
changes other than Kamala Harris who
spiked big but then came back down to
Planet Earth so tonight I doubt that we
are going to see much substance as usual
because the format just doesn't allow it
these debates are not listen if you
wanted to really learn the most depth
and detail about the positions of the
candidates you would have a completely
different set up with ten people on
stage never mind twenty obviously not
having twenty on stage as the right
decision even with ten people on stage
and these short answers and sporadic
even shorter rebuttals you're just not
going to learn a lot about the
candidates so we are likely to see
candidates bring these sort of planned
gotcha moments to the table like Kamala
Harris did with Joe Biden in that first
debate because unfortunately this is the
way to actually make an impact in the
debate so I'm going to be watching again
given that the debate format is so not
conducive to depth I will be watching
for do any candidates have those types
of gotcha moments that will cause
substantive changes to the leaderboard
for the third debate which is in
September September 12th and 13th
tentatively still scheduled for two
nights but may end up only being one the
requirements gets stricter candidates
will need both at least 2% in four polls
from an approved list of polls and will
need one hundred and thirty thousand
unique donors you need at least 400
donors from each of at least 20 states
so if we applied that standard today
there would only be eight candidates
remaining in them in the next debate
meaning that they can consolidate to
just one night if the debate three
requirements were applied tonight the
only candidates remaining would be Biden
Budaj
Harris
Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren Cory
Booker Beto or Roarke and yes Andrew
yang for me the most interesting thing
you all know that I've been interviewing
Andrew yang before anybody was
interviewing him or almost anyone and we
have been talking about what is his path
forward because after in the immediate
aftermath of that first debate didn't
really get much of a bump as it turns
out Andrew yang as of today if we
applied to the third debate standards
would be one of the eight candidates
remaining Castro would be out Amy
Klobuchar would be out Tom Steyer would
obviously be out Tulsi Gabbard would be
out Hickenlooper Williamson Inslee
Gravelle they would all be out but
Andrew yang would be in with those final
eight if we applied those standards
today so that is very very interesting
we have to consider tonight the kind of
last chance last-ditch effort for at
least some people what will you be
looking for tonight let me know who do
you think has an opportunity to really
climb in the polls last time nobody
emailed me and said I believe Kamala
Harris is the one who's going to spike
people were talking about I could be
Budaj edge it could be Gabbard it could
be yang most of that didn't happen
Andrew yang actually getting up to 2.3
percent what are you looking for tonight
let me know and I hope that you will
join me live for coverage of the debates
for as long as CNN allows it on our
youtube channel youtube.com slash the
David Pakman show